in the early 1960s Europe was
experiencing a baby boom renault baz
pierre Dreyfus responded with the
development of a radically new interior
design for a midsize car
[Music]
Jemison Adina car tester Christophe
Bauer recalls what Dreyfus announced to
his team we've got to see things in a
new light a car cannot always consist of
four seats a hood and a trunk
we've got to see it as a single space
the result was the 1961 Renault r4 a
revolutionary and innovative compact car
and a 1965 Renault launched the r16 a
mid-sized family car with a hatchback
large trunk lid and flexible interior
kocha during the design process the
engineers had almost total freedom the
only requirement was a front-wheel drive
in just four years the newly established
below to style progressed from a
prototype to a production model
r16 and built a new production facility
and Santo Vito near the ha
[Music]
Cristo says when the r16 was launched
the media was impressed they praised the
cars of benchmark and symbol of
practicality and held it up as a
challenge to German engineering even
today the car is still a smooth and
comfortable ride granted the steering is
a bit squishy and going around curves
can be nerve-racking but overall this is
a great set of wheels enclosing Gunson I
wouldn't of August as a kid and so the
Renault r16 became an international hit
initially sales figures doubled year by
year by 1972 seven years later Renault
had sold over 1 million
r16 Renault kept producing the car until
1980 continually developing new versions
including a luxury TX model with over 90
horsepower electric windows and 5-speed
manual transmission crystal says the r16
has a unique design the two box design
is a particular feature it broke with a
conventional design at the time where
vehicles were divided into three boxes
the engine in front the passenger
compartment and the trunk in back in
contrast the r16 fused the passenger and
trunk space allowing for a flexible
interior with up to seven different
variations
Zebari on Smotrich cuttings at that
level there's the so-called normal
position for when you're just driving
and the transport accepts your now
position for transporting large items
the back seat can be folded away
entirely then there's a position where
they to relax as well as the couchette
position for sleeping and cuddling back
then the Renault 16 had one of the most
spacious and comfortable interiors of
any midsize car need features like the
continuous ventilation grille and a
classy ashtray express a typically
French charm
another clever feature metal rails along
the flared pagoda roof
they provide stability and function as
roll bars oddly the torsion bar
suspension z' were installed one behind
the other
making the wheelbase six centimeters
longer on the left side than on the
right car Chester Christoph says there
we have it
spare tire as well as a redesigned
one-point liter four cylinder engine
with fifty-five horsepower the engine
block cylinder head and gears are made
from a lightweight aluminium alloy to
achieve better balance the gears are
located ahead of the front axle while
the engine sits behind more typical of
modern sports cars so the Renault was
actually ahead of its time
by modern sport wagon football turd mine
was an outside ambition for Elsa
and this raspy yet melodic sound is
quite enchanting krysta feels the r16
stands for the famous French lifestyle a
bit eccentric but very likeable and
easygoing road bumps Punta probably the
r16 suspension smooth them right over
too lazy to change gears
you can go 40 kilometres per hour or
faster than just third or fourth gear
and the seats are as soft as a sofa up
to the more comfortable overall a pretty
relaxing right the r16 really lives up
to Reno's old cars for life slogan it
can be customized according to every
owners special wishes until this day
Renault has a reputation for building
great family cars and laid the
groundwork for this with a 1965 r16
Krista reckons Renault built the right
car at the right time it was produced
for 15 years from the mid 1960s until
1980
an impressive record as the first
mid-sized sedan hatchback with a large
trunk lid and flexible interior it set
the standard for mid-sized sedans
as such the r16 is a milestone and
automotive history automobile she did
overall 1.8 million our 16s were built
but very few models are still in good
condition today owners took Renault
slogan quite literally and drove their
cars hard whew our 16s were sent in for
repairs or to the carwash for that
matter as a result many gradually wore
out overtime